so you just traded in your dirty old
phone
it's now part of the 64.5 billion dollar
second hand phone market
in 2022
73.5 million used and refurbished phones
were shipped in North America alone
exploding business and that's because
phone makers and the cellular carriers
have pushed us all to trading trade in
trade it trade it in for something new
that suits your life now but who's
winning and losing in this booming
Market when I asked the carriers and
apple to show me where the phones go and
if and how they make money on them they
wouldn't speak about specifics that's
why I came here to a warehouse in the
middle of New Jersey
[Music]
every week this facility owned by U.S
mobile phones receives tens of thousands
of devices primarily Apple from cellular
carriers so this is uh three pallets
that just came in and it should be
around 3 000 iPhones the company then
sells those phones some go to
wholesalers in other countries others
get cleaned up put through the
refurbished process and sold to
individual buyers on sites like Amazon
or back Market a popular refurbished
phone Marketplace we got an iPhone 11.
this one's a great example because it's
still kind of dirty yep I picked out
that 128 gigabyte iPhone 11. to track
the cycle and how it goes from arriving
here with a trade-in value of 200 to
leaving here with a price tag of three
hundred and fifty dollars to understand
we have to go through the refurbished
process
the first stop for iPhone 11 data
Erasure and triage we take the phones we
start connecting them over here to these
computers that are all running special
software to remove any potential
customer information from the devices
after that is put
to play some white no Shadows now
checking the Reds good status though
right so you take a screenshot now hit
the slide switch up and down say cheese
that obviously does not look good so
that's because of you you're not gonna
blame the phone for that say cheese
so that was it checking speaker on the
front over here checking flash you see
the light on my end so you can say yes
it's on I'm really not good at this it's
okay it's day one you're doing pretty
good
the device is now do a test call
success our iPhone 11 passed all the
tests
The Next Step cleaning
toothbrush plastic cakes microfiber
cloths foam sponges hand sanitizer
that it's on to grading where someone
looks over the device and signs it a
grade so they know how to price it
gonna look at the front glass the
housing the back glass if there's any
scratches success again our device got
an A
and the final stop kidding
we're gonna take this and put it into a
kit box so that we can get this shipped
out to our customer U.S mobile phones
has a sister company called back in the
box which is responsible for selling
refurbished phones directly to Consumers
on sites like Amazon and back Market
before the phone is shipped the company
packages it with a charging cable and
with lots of padding I'm gonna drop it
drop it I mean you could drop it there's
poor phone
okay so now it's ready but how much is
someone going to pay for it well for
some context Apple doesn't make the
iPhone 11 anymore but you can still buy
a brand new 128 gigabyte model for
around 500 at some retailers back in the
Box obviously has to undercut that
typically what we like to do is we like
to price refurbished products depending
on the grade between 20 to 30 below its
retail price and generally that gives a
good discount for the consumer and gives
us enough margin somewhere between 10 15
percent to be able to have some money
you have some profit to then go and buy
more inventory and support the business
on its website Apple says the trade-in
value for a used good condition iPhone
11 is 200 back in the Box told me it
bought the iPhone 11 from a carrier for
around 250 dollars then after the phone
was refurbished it listed it for 350 on
back Market which takes a 10 cut of that
sale back in the Box takes home around
sixty five dollars but that's not all
profit put a ton of Labor into cleaning
that device there's also a charger in
that box that we have to pay for there's
also a ton of devices that came with
that either at a bad battery or had some
other defect that we had to sell at a
loss so we have to make enough profit on
the good ones to be able to absorb the
hit on the bad ones
so what did we learn here today well
that there are more winners than losers
in this business
the cellular carriers win when you trade
in an old phone and buy a new one
refurbished companies win when someone
buys a refurbished phone and consumers
and the environment went along the way
the downside is maybe to the stock price
of the manufacturers that want to sell
as many brand new retail products
perhaps but even for Apple if all these
phones end up in the hands of more
people particularly in developing
countries it means growing market share
and more people buying into the iPhone
circle of life
that's all I got for you